Fais ta prière!!
Pourquoi moi??
Tu sais très bien pourquoi!!
Mais qu'est-ce que j'ai fait??
Si tu coopères pas je te descends, t'entends?!
Je vous dis que vous devez vous tromper de personne...!
Je vais te buter!
Je te le jure!
Alors pense à ta femme, pense à tes gosses...
Mais j'ai 17 ans...
Okay, t'en fais qu'à ta tête...
je vais t'explosé la cervelle...
tu entends je vais t'exploser la cervelle!!
3....... - Non!!
- 2....... - arrêtez, arrêtez!!
1..... - non!!
Okay, c'est bon, je le fais...
Bon, ben, merci
C'est souvent que t'arrêtes des gens dans la rue pour leur demander ça????
Tout le temps. C'est comme ça que je suis arrivé à 2 millions d'abonnés.
En tout cas c'est sympa de t'être abonné à ma chaine
et d'avoir mis un pouce vert sur ma vidéo.
Ah, par contre j'ai jamais mis de pouce vert...